es momento de la información económica
aquí en France 24 por ello me acompañan
el estudio mi compañero Jorge Hurtado
Jorge bienvenido hoy vamos a hablar del
impacto económico de las huelgas de Los
camioneros en Chile bueno estas
movilizaciones que empezaron desde el
lunes van a continuar precisamente
porque fracasaron los diálogos entre Los
camioneros y el gobierno chileno la
confederación de transportistas fuerza
del Norte y la agrupación de
propietarios y conductores de camiones
Rain paine reclaman al gobierno de
Gabriel boric una rebaja del precio de
los combustibles y mayor seguridad en
las rutas de transporte Pese a que el
gobierno chileno llegó a un acuerdo con
cinco de las agrupaciones Ha habido
según ellos grupos que han mantenido una
interrupción del funcionamiento normal
de las carreteras las autoridades
prometieron aplicar el peso de la ley
para desbloquear los caminos la labor de
los conductores de carga es vital en
Chile un país de geografía angosta y que
no cuenta con alternativas para
movilizar mercancías más allá
precisamente el transporte terrestre
escuchamos que dicen las partes
nuestra peticiones son súper claras son
tres puntos muy básicos
alza de combustible en el país dos
delincuencia y tres puntos de descanso a
lo largo de todo nuestro país ya con
esas tres puntos de peticiones nosotros
ya llevamos una movilización ya muy
establecida insisten en la paralización
afectando la vida de miles de
compatriotas y un esto quiero ser muy
claro no vamos a permitir que se
bloqueen las rutas de movilidad de los
chilenos y chilenas de nuestra patria
por lo tanto vamos a aplicar toda la
fuerza de la ley chile entero está
enfrentando una delicada situación
económica y no es momento para que este
tipo de actividades interrumpan el buen
curso de la economía justamente cuando
estamos en momento de reactivación Jorge
pero la protesta ya está afectando a la
población local e incluso está
comprometiendo las exportaciones
Valentina y es que debido a estos
bloqueos la asociación de supermercados
dice que la zona más afectada de es el
norte del país incluyendo las ciudades
de Valparaíso y San Antonio también los
exportadores hablan de una situación
crítica para el embarque de fruta en
Valparaíso uno de los principales los
puertos chilenos cuyo acceso se
encuentra bloqueado para el tránsito de
los productos que están destinados a la
exportación chile exporta alrededor de
5000 contenedores de frutas a la semana
lo cual equivale a 500 millones de
dólares situación que se ha visto
fuertemente interrumpida por estos
bloqueos de rutas realizado por el paro
de Los camioneros le preguntamos a
nuestra corresponsal en Chile Patricia
Luna sobre el impacto para los locales y
su repercusión en las exportaciones del
país esto Dijo
quinto día consecutivo de huelga de
camioneros en Chile que demandan una
reducción del 30% en los precios de los
Diesel y también mayor seguridad en las
carreteras estas demandas ha sido
calificadas como desproporcionadas por
parte del gobierno de Gabriel borich
quien ha invocado la ley de seguridad
del estado que supone penas de cárcel
efectivas para aquellos que lo inflijan
y que ha llevado a que se detengan las
negociaciones que se estaban llevando a
cabo entre el gobierno y el sector que
agrupa a 40.000 camioneros 30.000 de
ellos de pequeño y mediano tamaño
mientras el desabastecimiento comienza a
ser una posibilidad real para los
supermercados muchos de ellos avisan que
si esto continúa el fin de semana va a
poder empezar a notarse un
desabastecimiento en sus estanterías
mientras que en el norte donde se inició
la huelga varias nacionalidades reportan
la falta ya de combustibles la geografía
angosta de chile que hace que tengan en
carreteras que atraviesan 3.300
kilómetros de norte a sur como la ruta
Panamericana o la cinco sur hace que el
95% de los de las necesidades se cubran
a través del transporte por carretera es
decir se transportan no solo alimentos
sino también combustible maquinaria o
material de construcción entre muchos
otros otro de los sectores que está
afectado es el sector de la exportación
agrícola que constituye una parte
importante de la economía chilena y que
afirma que al tener bloqueados dos
puertos en Valparaíso por el que se
exporta el 81% de la fruta mucha de la
fruta que está en camino en este momento
podría echarse a perder y que si esto
continúa el próximo miércoles se podría
haber afectado hasta un 10% de la
campaña total de cereza que chile
exporta a China de forma masiva estas
son algunas de las consecuencias de
estos cinco días de paro a los que no se
vislumbra por el momento Un fin Jorge
Pues a usted muchas gracias por esta
ampliación económica yo por ahora los
dejo con mi compañero Santiago López
González que ya llega una semana en el
mundo
[Música]